All right, next, an incredible story
about how even the most difficult times
can bring out incredible good in people.
It's about two college kids who came together
to help families a world away.
The Washington Post reports that Harvard students
Avi Schiffmann and Marco Burstein
joined forces to build a website in just three days
to help Ukrainian refugees and find places to live.
It's called Ukrainian Take Shelter,
and it functions kind of like Airbnb.
If you have a house, apartment, a room,
even a couch to share, you can post it.
It doesn't matter where you live.
People are offering spaces in Poland, Romania, Canada,
the US, with some hosts even offering
to cover airfare to get them there.
And refugees can come with pets.
Some have, you know, their pets with them.
Avi and Marco built this site
to operate in many languages, also, which is so clever.
Polish, Ukrainian, Czech, and English.
It's so usable, they set it up literally within days,
and for more information on this,
you can go to our website at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
to get information on that.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
And it's so good.
It's good, you know, of course there are
really tough things going on, we all know that,
but the are moments like this, things like this,
that remind me, remind us all,
of the good that comes out of this,
about human decency and kindness and coming together,
so well done you two.
Very inspired.
Yeah, those boys
just have my heart.
I saw that story and I just wanted to relay it
as soon as possible.
Yeah. I love it.
Well, next up, we've got an incredible story
about two single moms joining forces to buy their own home.
Listen to this.
In her essay on Insider, single mom Holly Harper
shares the story that she and her friend, Herrin Hopper,
another single mom, were divorced and looking
for some housing stability and they couldn't do it alone.
So they formed a partnership
and bought the perfect multi-unit home together.
Then they rented out the additional units to two more women,
so now the house includes, okay, ready?
Five kids, three dogs, two hamsters, and a gecko,
and they say this built in community has been great
for the kids because they meet a ton of neighborhood people,
lots of support with childcare, carpools, dog walking.
This is another story about people coming together
when you just need humankind to take care of one another.
I mean, as someone who became a single mom,
this story just really spoke to me.
I was desperate for community.
I moved from Los Angeles to New York,
I felt very alone,
and I think I've always made jokes with my friends
about like, "One day shouldn't we just all live
on a commune anyway?"
Yeah, yeah, come on.
I think safety
is in numbers, I think this is such a brilliant story.
I kind of hope that it's a spark that ignites a movement.
I am so moved by this story.
Yeah, and it shows that you can define
what your family is, right?
There's no mold to fit.
And if we can take care of each other in any way possible,
we should do it.
I just am wondering how many bathrooms are in this house,
because there are a lot of people there.
That's a good point, Rossy.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)